the peer review process for journal
publication is essentially a quality
control mechanism
it is a process by which experts
evaluate scholarly works
and its objective is to ensure a high
quality of published science
however peer reviewers do not make the
decision to accept or reject papers
at most they recommend a decision at
peer-reviewed journals
decision-making authority rests solely
with journal editors or the journal's
editorial board
indeed it is the journal editor who is
considered to be central to the
decision-making process
typically after a paper is submitted to
a journal
a journal editor screens the manuscript
and decides whether or not to send it
for full peer review
only after clearing the initial
screening is the manuscript sent to one
or more peer reviewers
finally journal editors or the journals
editorial board consider the peer
reviewers reports
and make the final decision to accept or
reject the manuscript for publication
approximately 3 million manuscripts are
submitted to journals every year
given the large volume of manuscript
submissions more and more journals
follow a policy of screening papers
before sending them for full peer review
journal editors typically look at
hundreds of manuscripts a year
one of the first items that editors will
look at is the cover letter
and they may not get further than the
cover letter if the study does not seem
interesting enough
therefore it is imperative that authors
craft a well-written cover letter that
highlights the significance and strength
of their research as well as provides a
good reason why the manuscript is a good
fit for the journal
editors will then go through the
abstract and may even skim through the
introduction
figures and tables or other sections of
the paper to determine whether the
manuscript passes their quality
threshold
during the initial screening journal
editors mainly check the following
does the manuscript fit the journal
scope a name and will it be of interest
to the readership
is the manuscript of minimum acceptable
quality
is the content and writing good enough
to make it worth reviewing
and is the manuscript compliant with the
journal's instructions for authors
the manuscript clearly lies outside the
scope of the journal
then a rapid rejection allows the author
to quickly find and submit their
manuscript to another journal
peer reviewers time is wasted when they
have to spend time evaluating
and giving feedback for a manuscript of
clearly inferior quality
once a manuscript clears the initial
screening it is sent for peer review
there are three common types of peer
review for journal publication
first single blind where the names of
reviewers are not revealed to authors
second double blind where the names of
reviewers and authors are not revealed
to each other
and third open peer review where the
names of authors and reviewers are
revealed to each other
generally a minimum of two or up to six
peer reviewers are chosen for the peer
review
peer reviewers are ideally experts in
their field
journals usually build a pool of peer
reviewers that have a good track record
of producing high quality reviews
or they may scan the bibliography to
identify potential reviewers or contact
researchers they met at conferences and
seminars
many journals will first ask potential
reviewers whether they are willing to
review the manuscript before assigning
them as reviewers
editors have to be careful to select
reviewers who have sufficient subject
matter expertise to do justice to the
manuscript
therefore highly technical papers or
papers from niche subject areas may take
longer to review
because it may take editors some time to
locate appropriate reviewers
some journals give authors the option of
recommending preferred and non-preferred
reviewers
authors would do well to take advantage
of this option if available
as it can expedite the review process
since it saves the journal time and
looking for reviewers
the peer review is completed once all
the reviewers send the journal a
detailed report with their comments on
the manuscript and their recommendation
typically journals ask reviewers to
complete their reviews within three to
four weeks
however few journals have a mechanism to
enforce the deadline
which is why it can be hard to predict
how long the peer review process will
take
the journal editor or editorial board
considers the feedback provided by the
peer reviewers
and arrives at a decision the following
are the most common decisions that are
made
first accept without any changes
the journal will publish the paper in
its original form
second accept with minor revisions
the journal will publish the paper and
asks the author to make small
corrections
third accept after major revisions
the journal will publish the paper
provided the authors make the changes
suggested by the reviewers and editors
fourth revise and resubmit
the journal is willing to reconsider the
paper in another round of decision
making after the authors make major
changes
and fifth reject the paper
the journal will not publish the paper
or reconsider it even if the authors
make major revisions
the first option except without any
changes is rare
the second decision except with minor
revisions is typically the best outcome
authors should hope for
once a journal rejects a paper outright
authors are well advised not to resubmit
to the same journal
if the journal wanted to reconsider the
paper they would have issued a
conditional rejection
an outright rejection means that the
journal thinks the paper will not meet
its publication standards or interests
even after heavy revisions
editors decision making policies vary
some reject when even one peer reviewer
recommends rejection
some when the majority recommend
rejection and some only when all
reviewers recommend rejection
it is common for peer reviewers to give
conflicting feedback on the same
manuscript
one journal editorial went as far as to
say unanimity between reviewers is rare
in cases of conflicting feedback the
journal editor may choose to send the
paper to a third reviewer before
arriving at a decision
and the author may have to wait longer
for the peer review process to be
completed
in summary because of a large number of
submissions
top-tier journals are often forced to
reject even high-quality manuscripts for
various reasons
like a large number of submissions or
lack of fit with the journal's editorial
focus
while reviewers and editors easily agree
on what is clearly not acceptable for
publication
deciding what is worthy of publication
is a tougher challenge
finally journal editors make decisions
to accept or reject papers
based on their opinion of the paper's
publication worthiness and reviewers
comments